foreign
you guys ever heard of Ashraf Hakimi
soccer player that's like a real person
I just made them all I've freestyle the
name all right so he's a soccer player
from Morocco here in about a million a
month a million a month yeah play soccer
soccer is big big balls wow that kind of
reactions that play soccer dude I mean I
know it is even good logically it's a
worldwide sport I don't even know how to
gauge right yeah I mean it's it's gonna
be more than football because like the
audience is just worldwide yeah it's
Global so um so this guy you know pretty
rich dude his wife ends up filing for
divorce and you know what happens when
that heard about this yeah cool she gets
50 she's demanding half of his even in
Morocco or do they live in California it
sounds like California
I know like in lots of different
countries that is sort of the standard
but um I figured like in the Middle East
you could like if your wife goes I want
to divorce you just slap her and get it
we are divorced then yeah leave
no nobody does that
I would maybe if he's a fat old
billionaire but he's an athlete she
probably found him attractive she was
like I gotta catch yeah they look like
an attractive couple yeah that's legit
but turns out
he doesn't own any property homes cars
jewelry or even clothes because
everything he has is under his mother's
name City boys
including 80 of his total income ever
earned
very smart it's all in his mom's name
that sounds like some tax evasion [__]
though [__] it worked it was more it's
getting paid regardless his mom's gonna
pay it yeah yeah oh yeah yeah the tax
will get paid exactly oh because she's
the employee it just can't be taken
because it's not his that's not Bob
Marley model Bob Marley did that too he
used to put a lot of his song credit
like the writing credits instead of his
name he'd put other people's names and
like like what's the big one like No
Woman No Cry yeah that's he put that
writing Credit in the name of like this
dude in Jamaica who ran a soup kitchen
like this dude was a good ass dude and
he's like yeah that didn't be set up for
life
Wow and like it was a big thing because
like after Bob died his manager always
people trying to get the money like no
they try to fight for this this credit
and they could get it because it's
already all the points went to that dude
he splits he was known for like
splitting points up like giving his
family and like cousins like writing
credit writing credit writing credit
writing credits he doesn't need it yeah
this is the new hack this is the new
standard yeah and not to pay taxes so no
prenup give it to your mama give it to
your mom put in your mom's name yeah but
this isn't true love yeah right that's
true that's true what happens in that
company
let me lift you off during your hardest
times and she helped you out I would say
like you know it's kind of worth it like
maybe a part of a big part of that
success was because you just nutted so
good he was so relaxed all this but also
like I don't know like I think for me
like I'm not married but if I ever do
get married it'll be to someone who like
if I say like yo I love you almost the
rest of my life with you but I just
don't want to get married they love me
so much they're like for sure we'll
figure it out we'll be together forever
like that's we're getting married right
yeah yeah it's the same thing like hey
we're getting married like our blue like
a prenup she's like cool no worries I'm
like we don't need one like I need
someone with that amount of Faith yeah
yeah I know people like I have a friend
who
has a billion dollars and like his his
family's money right and so it's
inherited it's it they're still very
much alive like they're like if they
have a family wow they own a couple
teams you know what I mean and um his
big brother got married and so Stephanie
brought the fiance a prenup like hey to
sign this and she was like outraged like
no no I made a whole big thing right my
friend gets married famous the same
thing brings her freed up She Goes
gives it back to right away signs it
immediately he's like you're the one
forever yeah that's dope man you know
what I mean so it's like if you're
getting if you're divorced and the first
thing is like give me half your [__]
money he might have seen some [__]
coming yeah yeah yeah it's too obvious
too yeah I believe until death do us
part right so if we do part it's a
suicide pact yeah
homicides it didn't work out we're both
gonna [__] go we're going out yeah
um I'm a big believer in that yeah I
just don't think I don't know I think
like you can create this whole new uh uh
way of doing things everyone's
redefining what cohabitation is anyway
and the the idea of marriage I think
like you could create your own contract
for sure right it's like but the thing
is States like California or whatever
um prenups and stuff I heard sometimes
it doesn't even work yeah some some
state laws so your contract is based off
the the laws of the state so if the laws
of the state say like let's say the
whole tenure thing where you're like
domestic partners then that supersedes
anything you can put in your content
yeah because you don't even have to be
together like married but if you've been
living together for like 10 years she
could be entitled to what is that called
like a common law or something I think
so but like for example if Nick goes
like hey uh Bart I want you to kill me
for a hundred bucks
and that's the contract but if the
federal law is murder is illegal that
nullifies right right so it's like
whatever sorry dude it didn't work so
like the main laws
yeah damn no peanut you didn't do that I
didn't sign a prenup no no I didn't sign
up my wife's the breadwinner
I was like no I'm not [__] assigned
it I was like this is insulted
I was like this is [__] I was like I
love you okay I feel like prenups make
sense when you come from a prestigious
family that's extremely rich and you
need to and then you have a trust and
then one yeah yeah and and the children
become a part of it then like you're
bringing in non-blood relatives to the
family that have access to the fund yeah
yeah so I think like all these things
like a commoner like me just doesn't
have that level of like wealth and
access so I it's just a agreement
between me and my partner so it's like
if I'm a self-made then it's like yeah
that that wealth can be split that way
but then if you think about what if my
great great grandpa built something and
it can all be ruined because of my
stupidity and choice and I'm like that
makes sense when it comes to prenup and
things like that you think of Legacy
yeah that's true other people's
interests are involved yeah yeah yeah
because it's like now I'm affecting my
brothers you know future or like you
know their families or whatever my
cousins or whoever's tied to it what
happens in a divorce when you have like
a husband and wife that are both super
self-made with their own individual
assets like what even sometimes they'll
just agree to like we'll just keep it
separate and we don't owe each other
anything that's cool that's kind of
tight I need to switch property
is this a shirt by survival the judge
the classic switch like damn it but Jeff
bezel's wife man or ex-wife she
but she was female right married prior
to him yeah yeah no that one's different
like she definitely had to apply a big
part in like probably I got some ideas
yeah did she support him
I would say like a big big thing as to
um like what would make it fair is like
in you in those cases right usually one
has a stable income and they're
supporting while the other one's the
entrepreneur and you hear these stories
a lot right right would have like a like
a stable job like nursing or whatever
and then she'll pay the base bills well
did it didn't Geo do that when you guys
were starting JK didn't she say so GEOS
my wife is like more similar to the
situation where you're talking about
where in the beginning when I graduated
college I didn't me and Joe didn't
really know what we're gonna do I'm like
damn do I go like the typical Moore
school path or do we pursue YouTube
where at the time like AdSense was
making like I don't know like 300 bucks
a month I mean that doesn't really
sustainable but my wife Geo was already
working at the bank she was a personal
banker making good money and so she told
me she was like you can pursue whatever
you want and I'll support you so that
was already like oh [__] that's [__]
tight and then as talks got more serious
you know when you start talking about
like when you're you know day a few
years and you're talking about family
and what the future might look like you
were even married that was just dating
that was just dating yeah yeah she was
just down she was just down and then and
then she was like
um which is talking about like the like
you know just family like just normal
like talk that you guys usually have for
her her parents are together so they
have one house and then they have four
kids so if their parents pass probably
gonna sell the house and liquidate right
I have two parents they're divorced they
both own each house I only have one kid
so I mean I'm the one kid so I'm gonna
be someone that inherits two houses she
was like way early on she was like Hey
if you want to sign a prenup or
something like that like I'd be totally
down because I get it she was like those
your parents worked hard from a divorce
to have their own two houses I was like
you're pretty [__] dope dude yeah
that's pretty nice that's the wave see
I'll do it whether you know whether or
not I want you to marry her again what's
the opposite of a gold digger yeah yeah
yeah so we don't have a female or a gold
Giver
[Laughter]
so yeah everything we have is just it's
like like Joe's philosophy where it's
like tell death to us apart is really
how we look at it and if one day I get
set on fire and I'm like always
paralyzed whatever it could happen she
could have everything you know we'll
always just take care of each other in
each other's families no matter what
yeah it's real [__] yeah like the
medieval ways you know damn [__] but I
think it's easier when you're self-made
like it's you're easier when it's just
you but if it's like if you're
inheriting like going back to like his
his friend's idea like that's a whole
different level of you gotta protect
right that's a responsibility yeah yeah
it makes sense yeah but if it's just you
and you made it and it's like
okay just who cares whatever yeah yeah
she she is not gonna get that money like
they're gonna come after her but they're
gonna be like bro he did the exact thing
you need to do he did he's gonna come at
his mom bring his mom in court she's 85.
yeah so give me a quarter every day how
much is she fighting for like 50 50.
half of that 20 what happens if the ball
if the mom passes that the money go to
him and then to her I don't know who the
like he could create a trust and then
priority did yeah separate it he must be
like several steps ahead this probably
isn't the first like line of defense
there must be like many but I feel like
athletes just have a whole different
level of like I have to protect myself
because like you don't know who's
actually smart yeah or they just sign
everything you put in front of them yeah
I thought there's a level of head that
if head is too good you should be scared
yeah yeah you better watch it back she
has a Target on you yeah you should know
like that was too good we need to get a
sign of [__] prenup yeah yeah she's
onto something yeah yeah she might take
this whole [__] down one yeah yeah that
was vicious like a tough and I had given
skills you are selfish
[Laughter]
perfect
foreign